when it comes to colonizing new worlds
Mars could be humanity's best option but
the journey won't be like it was in the
past for pioneers like Magellan Gagarin
and Neil Armstrong this new frontier
will be the most extreme challenge yet
it's not just learning how to survive on
an alien planet with less oxygen a
weaker gravitational pull and more
harmful radiation it's enduring the
changes that these extreme conditions
will have on the human body manipulating
it in ways that we can only begin to
imagine even astronauts know that you
don't have to spend much time off earth
to notice changes the lower gravity can
kick-start a whole list of physical
alterations just ask this guy
former NASA astronaut scott kelly he
lived for an entire year on the
international space station without
Earth's gravitational pull the
zero-gravity weakened his bones and
muscles and expanded the space between
his vertebrae making him two inches
taller now the zero-gravity environment
in space is more extreme than on Mars
however these changes could still happen
on smaller scales and if you compound
them over hundreds of years and tens of
generations the results could be similar
and even more pronounced basically
humans will adapt to Mars conditions in
one of two ways in the first few
centuries our skeletons and muscles will
likely shrink and will become weaker
versions of our earthling counterparts
this would almost certainly lead to
shorter lifespans and health
complications including neurological
disorders if our skulls shrank with the
rest of us so to survive we may over
millennia actually undergo the opposite
reaction evolving stronger more robust
bodies like the Tharks and edgar rice
burroughs a sci-fi novel a princess of
Mars
although us having six arms and green
skin is less likely in fact some
scientists think we can actually develop
porn skin not green turns out the
carotenoids that make carrots sweet
potatoes and pumpkins look orange offer
a certain amount of protection against
harmful UV radiation when we eat these
pigments in large amounts we actually
get a boost of protective carotene in
our bloodstream and under our skin so
yeah eating too many carrots can turn
you orange but it may also be a great
defense against cancer on Mars the
planets thin atmosphere lets in massive
amounts of UV and other high-energy
radiation compared to earth for example
the average earthling receives about 3
millisieverts of radiation per year
versus the 30 that they would get on
Mars to compare here's the minimum
radiation dose it takes to drastically
increase your risk of cancer add up the
annual radiation levels on Mars over a
lifetime and the average Martian would
receive 5,000 times more radiation than
someone on earth and our big orange
bodies may not just look different on
the outside one of the most profound
changes we could have coming is the next
species of human higher levels of
radiation on Mars a surface would mutate
the DNA in our cells at an accelerated
pace normally a species like Homo
sapiens could take a few hundred
thousand years to evolve on earth but
some scientists say the higher mutation
rate could spawn new human species
within centuries 10 times faster than on
earth so if the radiation didn't
outright kill us the mutations that
survived will be passed down through
generations
ultimately diversifying the gene pool
and allowing natural selection to do its
job
as exciting as it may sound there is a
potential downside to all of this
if one day in the future the Martian
falls in love with an earthly it can
only end in tragedy the immune systems
of Martians and Earthlings will be
completely different in a meeting
between the two could be just as deadly
as when two foreign groups have met in
the past like the European settlers who
gave smallpox to the Native Americans
also depending on how genetically
different they are even if they could
meet they may not be able to have
Martian Earthlings of their own since
only closely related species can
reproduce moving to Mars may be the best
chance for Humanity survival but it may
not be humans who lived there in the end